Hello,同学们,大家晚安
有看得到我吗?
来,这个我们正式课程会在15分钟后开始
然后现在就先跟同学来聊一聊
有同学问说我的收费课程该如何加入
没有办法加入,我没有要收
好不好
目前唯一剩下的收费你能够加入得到的
加入的到的大概就是這個頻道的會員
但其實包含今天要講的內容
就都是我在收費課程訓練同學在用的東西
你今天聽完其實你也不用加入了
你就自己練其實應該不會差距到太大啦
好不好
然後呢
我從我剛剛看到的幾個地方開始講
有一位同學他說他NQ15K打在8點31分
來
你打15分K
你打的位置是8点31分
代表
代表你打在这
你知道吗
对15K来说
这边完全不是一个好打的点
如果你跟我说你打5分K
你打在8点30
你打在这一根
如果你打5分K打在这一根
你知道你的防守要在哪里吗
你的防守要在哪里
整个这个东西
注意看哦
这里
这个边界的以外
对
老于这样的防守好远哦
是因为现在的K棒的大小变大了
不是防守远近的问题
你就照着K棒给你什么样子的位阶
怎么做
你就怎么做
为什么我会这样讲
如果你做15K
我相信这
不对对不起
如果你是做15k
这个边界你应该也看得出来
只是前面这边真的有点堵
但是就算你真的要堵
你知道吗
你也必须要这样子堵
这个边界
你不能守刚刚好
你要守它的这个地方
跟这个地方
跟这个地方的什么东西
以外像这样子
这是我直接目测的位置
这才是你该守的点
如果你刚刚是守
吃,其实15k我觉得不好吃啦
5分k就很明确一个互换的边界这边有個邊界上來,又來測這個才是最末端下不去的點
我不管你吃在這裡的哪一個點
你全部都是要鎖在下面
那個才是對的
這樣好不好
這很重要喔
然後
等一下喔
还有上面我记得我看到一些东西
有同学说Gogoro
我从上面看到再讲一下好了
Gogoro 我的Gogoro
我的Gogoro
根本我已经忘记它了
我是到前三天我才发现说
原来它从底下长上来
如果我有看到
其实我或许会多补一些部位
但是其实我根本就忘记这件事情
我就是丢着
那你说这边值不值得丢
还不错
这个边界如果回来这个边界
我觉得整体会演算算不错的东西
然后有同学说
为什么最早以前我会叫海归交易
如果你有
你早期你有看那个书
有一本叫做海归训练班
海归训练班的书它就是讲
交易员像海归一样是可以训练的
是可以养殖的啦
这样子讲
那那个书大家自己去找
网路上可能有电子版
我以前是看那个实体的书的这样
总之我一直都认为交易是可以训练的
所以从我早期大概十年左右吧
进华南的时候
然后一路到现在
我都还是认定交易可以训练
而现在比起十年前的我
又更进步了一点
我讲的是指我把整个交易的那个逻辑等等
我要如何交
以前是我会做
但是胶可能还要磨一下
但是随着这个过程
有Jack也有廖大
他们进来帮忙把这整个训练的计划
磨得越来越好
包含他们的经验
然后以至于现在大家看到的
这个东西就是
就是眼前的这个训练计划
今天会有比较多的时间来讲
训练计划
好不好
然后呢
所以这个
剛好像還有另外一位同學打小娜
同學說
小娜一小時收
尖尖的
對打在這邊翻亞當直接噴出去對我是沒有看盤我吃完這邊我根本就沒有看這段時間我不再盤錢我在旁邊
我在旁邊對著那個
我前面那邊有個球網
我在對著他丟棒球
在練捕手怎麼接這樣
我知道剛剛才練一練
才過來這邊坐著
好來
還有位同學說
9点40分是好的坡底翻吗
如果是这样子
我跟你说那边很美
我知道你在看哪里
这里
对
就是这里
那事实上我也是在这边开始有兴趣
来来来
打开我的交易给大家看
其实我很不喜欢他这个交易的呈现模式
先讲哦
这一堆
有没有看到这一堆
我在这个之前
大概账上是赚1400
然后呢
我就心里想说
嗯好我有1400
结果就拿来乱花
你知道吗
所以就觉得心里面就飘起来
反正今天有钱
了不起赔个700
就赔了
来
结果赔了以后
这边这个是我正常的做
我看我要怎么看
看1K好了
1K比较清楚
这边有一个1分K的这个
所以我在这边做被打掉
打掉就算了
我从这里开始醒过来
我先丢个三口测试
测试什么
先测试这个边界
对哦对哦好
行情来到这边
这个就是同学讲的7点40分的位置
19点40
你们看到我在这边
加3加3这里
加加这样子
所以这个是我先很低部位的去测试
这个市场对吗
对吗
对哦对哦好
如果错了我就三口赔掉
你知道以微型的三口来讲
是我可以承受得起
很低很低的风险
在这边加加加,我们要在赚钱的角度加码
有,好
然后赚钱的角度加码以后,这条线先拉走
来
上去又回来到这里,有没有看到我又加4
好,所以加3加3加3
然后这里又加4
我的防守就是均价,当时的均价约略在这附近
我没有很精准的记得在哪里
反正就是我把我的防守拉到均价
這樣,了不起就把我打掉
然後呢,這邊這個,有沒有看到我減一
減一的目的是為了讓我翻成正的如果今天這一段打掉我至少還有赚15块钱回家睡觉OKOK就是这样子
今天没有
如果就打掉了
我就占不到便宜
然后我就这样回去睡觉
也算还OK的
好不好
这是我目前眼前的交易
有同学说跟我吃在同一个地方
其实我跟你说
我先把这个拿掉
拿掉它那個很難看
來各位
如果
如果這個地方不是破底翻
什麼是破底翻你告訴我
我最近會比較常看1K
主要是因為我想要縮封控
最近的5分K或15分K
隨便一個就很大
那個封控一根
我要去防守那個引線的邊界
隨便一個就要30點50點
所以我只好縮到1分K
分开不过
今天给我市场给我的感觉
比较像是我
习惯的多头的感觉
简单的说
市场的速度变慢了
就连开盘前现在
它的速度都变慢
如果各位记得在两个礼拜前
四月初那时候
就连美股开盘前的速度
都是跟鬼一样
当速度跳动变快的时候
就是空头盘
即将来临的那种迹象
甚至是正在来临的迹象
要出场的人是不计价的乱卖
卖卖卖卖卖卖
他的想法是逃命
他不知道知道什么东西
可能有人先知道川普要讲话
不知道
总之有某些人不计价的要逃命
那为什么现在我的感觉是市场慢很多
各位
我好想要买
但是如果你的口袋没有钱
你是不是买不起
你可能要解定存
你可能要有的人还跑去贷款
解定存要时间
贷款下来也要时间
所以不管你是怎么做
要买的这个动作
要把钱丢进市场的这个动作
通常都会慢一点
所以这个是我们长期
做十几年来的经验
只要你看到那个坡洞
是这样
这样子的
你喜欢做多的人
今天就是手绑紧一点
哦
小心一点
那目前看起来的样子
是我自己习惯的
多头的那个样子
這樣好不好
目前看起來是這樣
那有同學說小娜回來加碼合理嗎
看你用幾分K
如果我剛剛其實
我本來在這個地方
在5K的這裡我本來想加
但是我剛剛在下單前
我看了一下15K
這15K的這個上影線
我看到他就很討厭
很討厭
然後我本來心裡想的是
哇今天可能
可能就這樣子沒有部位
可能就赚个297加15块
我可能就是赚这个钱回家了
因为我看到那个60分K长上引线
30分K也是15分K也是
所以我本来其实那时候开着5K
本来在这里
我这样瞄了一下
本来就想说要不要下
然后看了一下那个长上引线
算了算了就这样吧
对所以目前是这样
眼前我看到的惯性是仍然回来
我没有打算在这里加
因为这里的感觉
让我感觉是在中间
我要加干脆就贴着我的成本加
不然干脆就上去又回来加
这样好不好
那我同学说
我好像比较常开X
比Tradivate好用吗
也不是好用不好用
而是他们跟我说
如果我要上节目
那他们会邀请我上节目
他只能开X
所以我
我其实也很习惯
Tradleway那边的下单的模式
那绝对我来讲没有差
而且我觉得他那边的
那个下单的那个三角形的
那个箭头
比起这边的标示
友善太多了
他还会有那个赚培的那个线
我很清楚一目了然
但这边很讨厌
他就是只有标那个数字
那个
所以我都通常
我绝大多数的时间
我都是关掉
因为那个很
很乱
尤其是像我
我又不是一次只有一笔单
我是多部位分散的方式
用散弹的方式在打
但是这些散弹对我来讲
其实是同一个部位
只是我分批的这样
咚 试单
行情对咯 咚咚
这样子
还对咯 咚
我是这样子慢慢的试
试这个市场
这样好不好
哇 看来
只要这边撑不住
只要这里
这里是有一个破底翻的样子
这里就是这里只要这边撑不住我底下那个大概也没忘了所以我應該就不會動我的停力就讓他賺293回家今天很有可能就這樣子收工
好不好
來上面有同學問什麼呢
我們來看一下
3231周K
來我們看一下
剛剛好像有看到有同學問那個AMD
AMD很美啊
3232多少
尾創
周K吃在100算好位置嗎?
啊?周K喔?
吃在100喔?
100不就剛吃而已
嗯
好了你已經吃了我也不能說什麼
對我來講
好位置會是落在
落在90這個邊界上
如果你是吃在這個地方
哦 讚!如果今天這根K棒它是在這裡
你說周K喔
如果它周K是在這裡
K棒掉下來是在這裡
在這個地方鬼混鬼混鬼混
欸 你吃
哇 這個是一個周K很美的點
同樣美的點
剛剛有同學講AMD這裡
這個
這個就是有回來到這個邊界的
那個看AMD的同學
很不錯喔 這個是好點
然後還有一個那個Netflix
不是Netflix
NVIDIA來來來
NVIDIA的日線
各位我相信你應該知道我要講什麼
這個東西
這裡這裡這裡
喔這個對NVIDIA是
是很好很值得觀察的邊界
尤其是像昨天
昨天他硬生生的收進這個邊界內
喔這個就是你值得觀察的點
好不好
好,然後再來
我要講什麼
我要講
有同學說
每個影片要反覆的聽
實際上很多細節
一個晚上賺一萬多
朝聖
我還沒有你賺的多
其實很多同學都比我厲害
太多了
我現在打單的角度有點
有也好沒有也好很隨意
其實我覺得反而這個
會讓我能夠悠遊在這個市場中
剛剛就有一段時間不隨意
就有點太放縱的自己然後還好趕快趕快發現亂掉的自己趕快把自己拉回來這樣子剛才前面好像有看到一個同學說
這位
這位練交易三年
第一次滿足出金條件
但是有回撤
所以想要達到原來的金額再出金
哎呀
有兩單是你的單沒打
然後沉不住氣
連虧五單
不遵守日風控暴了
來我跟你說
你不是孤单的
我这边要是问旁边的同学
有这种
这种静观情怯的经验的举手
大家双手双脚会举起来
举到没有东西举
大家都一样
因为我们快要通关的那一瞬间
你的事业
会跑到那个金额上面去
这个我觉得是
这种通关制度的
不管哪一间公司都一样
它本质上的陷阱
因为你月道通关的那一瞬间
你一定会特别在乎说
我差200美金
我差300美金就可以过关
就可以拿到一个真实账号
或是说我差300就可以出金
哇
你的脑袋在说
我差300可以出金的那一秒钟
你已经想出金这件事
这一想就会造成这件事情
所以你说
你不用担心
大家都是要先踩过这种地雷
才会知道这种地雷不能踩
这个是每个人都要经历的一部分
所以我觉得你也不用太
太自责自己这样好不好
有同学加一加一加一百
NVIDIA右边
没有他这我跟你说
NVIDIA的右边
对涂鸦起来是比较低没错
但是要注意一件事情
他的意圖
市場的意圖
他跌下去的本來想要很低沒錯
但是卻被一個神秘力量硬生生收盡
你看收盡這個邊界
這個是市場他在告訴我的事情
理論上應該要收在下面才對
卻沒有卻收在這個地方以上
像這樣子我就會去觀察他的意圖
如果這個意圖延續了
可能有些人知道某些事
那我就跟跟看
我们不用当第一个
这样好不好
有同学说第一次看哥的直播哎呀掰好了今天赚294块我不干了虽然说这边可能有东西吃
但是不要了
我自己知道说
如果像这样被点掉的瞬间
我立刻再吃进去
我的心很容易缩在
刚刚被点掉的那个土里面
我今天就这样子
回家回家
那你说老鱼你刚刚为什么不收
你刚刚行情在这里
你怎么不收
我的计划就不是做这
我的计划是
我想要把这一段给做出去
这样子
做不出去
我能怎么办
就免费的乐透
赌输
好不好
就这样
来
先来看今天的这个主题
交易是可以训练的
这是我在
非常多年前
第一次开那个
现场的实战班的时候
那时候在华南
那时候的同学就是来现场
我们一起做单
现场哦
做两个礼拜
手把手的做
所以一方面在练人家的这个
练大家的这个
这个纪律啊
然后风控等等
好了
我说整套交易法是可以练的
其实旁边这些同学
包含刚刚会问出
很多好点的同学
大概你的脑袋都已经练得差不多了
这是我在前两天
发在FB上面的文
然后的最后面
如果說交易練習的順序
先有兩條線
再來畫出兩條線
再把這兩條線拿來做邊界亂打
價格到了直接吃
可以接刀
你可以甚至掛單都沒關係
我等一下會一個一個
好好的講解
我們先把整串看完
這算是大綱
邊界二就是延續兩條線
然後
這裡如果以接刀的角度
就是待會如果來這個地方
你就直接接
对
这就是接到的概念
因为就是
别一条线两条线这样
然后呢
如果是边界二
就是假设行情来到这个地方
那我不能在第一根下来的时候吃
我需要躲在隔壁
好不好
例如说这个
这里这里
这边界我讲解
行情一个点两个点
我可以画得出
两点一线
2.1线
可以连成一线
那我可以做什么呢
2.1线我就躲在这一根的隔壁
这就是边界乱打
第二阶段的2-1
還有一個二之二就是除了躲後面還要打在乾淨邊緣
等一下我都會一路的講
再來第五就是我們要練標準圖的辯證
什麼叫標準圖的辯證
例如說剛剛我們不是有同學在底下這裡
我們剛剛不是說老魚這是標準圖
對那你就會這樣塗鴉給我
老魚這裡是標準圖這樣子
然後你辯認給我塗鴉這樣子就像就塗這樣子東西給我
存檔交上來
我就會說
這是一個好的標準圖
這樣好不好
然後呢
翻亞當的練習
翻亞當很簡單
例如說這一根
一大根K棒
我們不會用一分K
但是先借我講解一下
一大根K棒離開盤整區間
好那我就把這一根鎖住
就這樣子把整個盤整框起來
咚咚
它應該要到這裡去
但是他告訴你到這邊差不多也滿足了
好 有沒有
任何一個格局都可以做這件事情
那這個前提是你要先定義出兩條線
哎呦 差點忘記取消
像現在眼前的30分K
我的兩條線其實很清楚
就是這樣 兩條線
所以如果有一根K棒
如果待會有一個K棒是這樣子的漲破
假設行情是這樣兩條線
行情來到這邊
然後漲破這個高點
那就是鎖住這一根
然後把這一段
咚
咚的翻出去
那這一根就是K棒的
實體K棒的高低點對齊
然後呢
懷孕兩條線
不要了
不要再兩條線了
我跟蔡阿嘎一樣
這輩子不會再有兩條線了
好不好
來
那個
接下來
打圖練習
等一下
我這邊要講一下
翻亚当练习是建立你对于
趋势的这个信心
然后注意亚当的重点
他是拿来抓出场目标
不能做进场用哦
不能说两条线要这样子
然后你就拿来追
然后追出去
不是不是
我们是买在两条线的下缘
出现破底翻
好我们买在这
然后坐上来
赌这个地方
番亚当把这一段懂得读到萤幕外面去我们的做法是这样子绝对不是看到了翻亚当然后还在这边追
然后想说把这个做后半段
No, No, No
我们不做后半段
我们要做在刚转折的第一段
他要转不转我不知道
我不想做在中间
就像刚刚
刚刚同学不是说要加码吗
我刚是不是说在这边
我不太想加
因为我认为那边不在
它不在
不在区间的哪里
边界
所以其实只有现在这附近的价格
这里
只有这附近的价格
我会比较喜欢
但是眼前我不想要吃
好不好
待会要美股开盘
而且目前看起来很凶的样子
我想要先等一下
OK
好再来
所以在打图练习的时候
你要综合上面所学的东西
你什么边界二的摸拉
就是这种行情下沙
咚咚两点一线
破了尖尖的隔壁
这种单子就不能吃
你只能等什么
来注意看
下沙咚咚破了
这边曾经走很下去
回来这个尖尖的隔壁
这就是尖尖的隔壁
不能吃
你要等什么
等行情這樣子
這樣子
這邊這邊這邊打尖尖的好
這時候再把尖尖的隔壁的能力
運用在就是你前面都練過了
我們都看過了OK
把這個能力用在這個地方
用在有標準圖的
這裡
我就不仔細畫了
然後你要堅持自己連續打多少張
不多
我只要求50張
通常我们的同学这50张
大概要花三个月到半年
才打得出50张
三个月到半年
快的大概三个月
慢的大概半年
那你说老鱼你设定这个
不就是你要要求同学们缴学费吗
没有
我的目的是
你要打出标准图才能出手
这个阶段是你要非常榜首的阶段
以棒球来说
你就会非常的挑
反正你不出手你不会死
巴菲特也讲过这个动作
棒球你不出手被删着你就下场了但是以交易来说你不出手不会怎么样只要有标准图的出手其实它的胜率整体下来是蛮高的
然后打到这个阶段以后
练完到自由打单
就是你这边都被我们
我们审核通过了
50张图我们都看过
你打得很标准
到自由打单的时候
我们就把你的权限打开
有些地方你要边界二德摩
OK
有些地方你要在
在标准图的时候吃OK
但是你自己就要开始控制
你的出手的频率跟次数
不能太多
然后多到说
整天一直摸都没有标准图
也不能说都没有弹性
说我只要标准图
但是偶尔有一些好的边界二
你就说
你就没有弹性就错过了
这个很难去
去拿捏
我曾经有个朋友
是以前我在华南的好朋友
叫Robert
他有一天写一段文字
他说交易是天平的两边
很保守的人
非常在乎风险的人
他赚不到钱
他会赔钱
他就是慢慢赔
他还是赔掉
很积极的人
他也会赔钱
而且他是快快赔
所以一个是慢慢赔
一个是快快赔
所以太保守
太积极
两个都不好
你要折中在中间
有些时候你要勇于让你的风险
让你的部位去承受风险
在可控制的情形下
有些时候要说
有些时候要冲
只有介于中间的
才能长期活在市场上
那这
最后这个阶段自由打单
我会要求同学们去参加考试
我要大家用真钱
不见得适合大家
因为每个人手上口袋的
那个真钱的刻度不一样
有的人只有10万
有的人有100万
有的人有1000万
每个人的刻度不同
我很难一起去去看
所以对大家风险最低
我又有可以在
你有压力下去
去改他们作业的这种情形
就是请大家去考试
考试的费用了不起
50块美金一个月
或是99块美金一个月
最多最多149美金一个月
反正就大概是这样子
以前我们最初期接触到TS的时候
那时候都没有打折
都是原价300多美金在做的
但是你知道吗就算是300多美金也比我过去用增仓自己的钱一个月我如果一个月乱掉
我的亏损金额绝对高于300美金
通常都是多一个或两个零
如果我乱掉的那个月
很恐怖
所以你用这个角度讲
因为我曾经赔过增钱
我们增钱赔过
一个晚上赔33000美金的
都在赔了
对吧
一个月赔掉
赔掉一两万美金的
爷在赔了
你就会觉得
哦好
我用300美金
360几吧
去测试这个
我的交易法
测试我的心
能不能稳定
哦好像还OK
所以前面这些
我都要求同学
不准考试
也不准用增仓
你只能用
你的模拟账号
而且模拟账号还不用花钱
也不用开户去注册
你用免费的email就可以去注册
都不用钱
用那个打给我看
然后
最后这边我要讲
每一个
你可以说上去的哦
真的耶
我这样好想下单哦
好了好了
应该不会有太多的风险
看一下这样子防守多少
三口一样三口先
这样
其实差不多了
这个感觉可以了
就这样子
还不会让我自己变富的
OKOK
来继续
我刚刚讲到来
上面这些练习
不能独立
你不能说老鱼说
说两条线画出来
价格到了可以接刀直接吃
你不能拿着这句话
回家去做老鱼说可以接刀
我会打死你
这个断章取义绝对不行
好不好
来开始好好的聊
像我们
有很细的去改同学的作业
然后同学在即将结业前
我们会发给他一个这种
这种他的练习通关的表格
我们什么时候认证过
我们都还会盖章
然后发给他这样
然后所以同学进来这里面
你也可以不照着练
你也可以照着练
那如果你要照着练
就是照顺序
我把第一階段先看完一些基礎影片
這些都是動態練習的影片
接下來練兩條線的靜態
以此類推
靜態練習
動態練習
所謂動態練習就是把
停止的兩條線
拿來在行徑當中
在行徑當中
去做出這個動作來
這樣好不好
然後後面這邊
來注意看我們說
出手的左邊
一定要有人擋子彈
我這邊很細的講一下擋子彈的這個動作
例如說
例如
我开这个出手给大家看
来哦
如果刚刚有人
吃做多
做多在
在这一根K棒的这里到这里
这个是乱摸
这个是乱拆
因为子弹从这边射过来
没有任何人
没有任何人要在这边
帮你挡子弹
你就是那个盾牌
有没有
子弹这里射过来
你就是盾牌
你怎么知道价格不会一直下去
你怎么知道
你不知道啊
但是你就猜了
不行
所以我喜欢的是一个边界
边界有跌破边界又收进来
各位看一下我上个礼拜
各位我不知道大家记不记得
在上个礼拜的这个影片
就这个礼拜四的影片的
最后面在这个影片的50几分这附近这里
然后当时我直接吃了一个
我放大给大家看
这样
我直接吃了一个边界
你说老鱼老鱼这里没有边界
因为我不是单纯看这个刻度
大家回去自己看
在这支影片的大概50几分的这里
上周四的直播
我吃了这边
然后一上去我就拉了不赔
这个动作就是我因为有这两个人
帮我撑腰
看刚刚的图
因为有他们帮我撑腰
有这个人帮我挡了子弹
我很懦弱
我是一个懦夫
我是胆小鬼
所以呢
我拿着别人的身体
他的身体来当盾牌
有没有
扛着人家的
在电影里面
那个特务很厉害的间谍
不都是会拿
敌人的身体拿在这边
躲在人家后面这样哟哟哟的打吗对吧如果你有玩斗阵特攻坦克在前面拿盾牌你是法师你是射手你就躲在坦克的后面
拿弓箭射
拿法术丢
拿火球丢
对不对
对就是同一个动作
我不希望自己的身体是盾牌
我很贱
我要拿别人的身体
好不好
然后像你看
如果你刚刚下单在
如果你下单在
我下单在这里
我怎么躲在这个人的
这个有厚度的盾牌的
子弹打过来
有1234
哇有四成的盾牌帮我挡
哦这是好事
所以我躲在人家这里面
如果你刚刚在1分K里面
你是吃单吃在
这个价格以下
在这一根
如果你吃在这边
这就不对了
因为对1K来说
这个1K是
子弹从这一根射过来
你又变成接刀仔
这样听得懂差别吗
你又接刀了
这是不行做的事情
懂这个想法
而刚刚我的这个位置
我吃的位置
其实我也躲在人家5分K的哪里
的体内
不是体
我躲在人家5分K的后面
就是这些人的身体
帮我当盾牌挡住
有没有
所以同样的东西来
如果你刚刚有在上面
在这个地方
做了空单
你觉得这是好空单吗
不行
你要空
子弹从这里射过来
你必须要躲在哪里
躲在最高价的内侧
这样好不好
那我这边继续要延伸来讲一个观念
很好玩的观念
来咯
我们还有边界乱打2-2
来
这一段的重点是
不只要有人挡子弹
你已经学会了两条线
你也学会了边界在哪里
你也学会了边界来了
下面
本来边界1就是
以刚刚的练习来说
边界1就是可以直接吃
边界二代表你下来的K棒
子弹射过来你必须要躲在后面对吧好我们来到边界二指二了来重点了来还要吃在干净边缘什么叫干净边缘
我跟大家有一个很明确的定义
实体K棒跟引线的这个边界
这个边界就叫做干净边缘
那为什么要吃在那里
来我要很细很细的讲解
好吧
我应该可以拉不赔了
好不赔
耶
那我还没有打算加码
因为市场也还没出去
而且待会要开盘
这开盘是个很难预测的东西
我就不打算加码
我们继续来延伸讲这个
这个边界二之二这件事情
来咯
我找一个案例
好
我上礼拜的这个正好是一个案例
上礼拜的这个
注意看
当时我吃的均价
我当时是在这边也挂单的吃
你们看到我的单子
是在这个边界这里
实体K棒跟
引线的交接数这里
这个边界
你知道吗
偶尔你会遇到
来我们从大科度来
你偶尔会遇到
60分K的
引线的边界
然后在这个地方的里面
等于5分K的这个东西
然后又有短格局引线的边界
简单的说
60K的大边界跟短格局的大边界
都约略的注落在同一个地方
而且都发生引线
你偶尔会遇到这件事情
如果你有遇到
这样子就代表你不是只有
一个人孤军奋战
你有大科度的人
还有小刻度的人一起在跟你一起往那个地方走
这个时候你的军队你的队友比较多
是不是这场战争你比较容易获胜
对吗
这个想法要放在心里
好不好
我其实知道这边容易往这边走
我其实知道
但是我不想加
我是站在风险的角度
来我要继续延伸哦
你看一下15K
各位
各位,15K有沒有看到這個18500這裡?就這麼剛剛好,有沒有看到這個關鍵邊界的這裡?也就是說我會希望你是下單在也對下單在這個乾淨邊緣
這根先借我拿出來講解
我希望你下單在這一根15K
漲漲疊疊 漲漲疊疊疊
好5 4 3 2 1 停住了
停住了以後
你觀察它的乾淨邊緣在哪裡
这个框框上一些下一些的这里
我无法跟你讲精准的价格
但是就是上下差不多
在这附近不可以下单在
各位看这边这是一根15分K的K棒
隔壁开盘如果开在这看我画的哦
如果他是这样子价格一路往下跌跌跌跌跌到这里
不可以吃单吃在相对这个下引线的下面
最低价这附近
绝对不行
为什么绝对不行
你想一件事情
如果市场都可以这边
收上来
对吧
隔壁开盘在这边
你想象一下
1分K里面
如果它市场从这边
会走到这里
让你在这个地方吃到单
它的1分K
是不是就是这样子
咻咻咻咻咻的下跌
所以你在吃到
这单的瞬间
请问你
惯性是往哪里走
在更小一个刻度的惯性
百分之百是往下走
对吧
所以这个百分之百往下走
你吃到这个地方很容易
就这样子把你打掉
这是不好的单子
这样可以理解吗
所以你需要什么
注意看哦
今天正好是一个好案例
当然前半段这边如果有有这样子更好
但是,這邊先借我講解
尖尖的隔壁這個地方
你需要它約略的停頓在
停頓在這個開盤架
就是輕的這一根的這個開盤架的附近
這樣,所以我很喜歡做的動作是什麼
來,我們先回到5K
我們回到,各位看一下這一根
我現在把K棒放很大
我不代表這邊能空,但是注意看
注意看,这边有没有一个
上不去的边界
涨上去上不去,上上去上不去
有没有
好来
上不去的边界我放很大
这根K棒
如果K棒往上涨
你在1850
565这里做空单
很容易被嘎上去
所以隔壁我会等
等什么呢
等K棒这样上上上上
上不去上不去上不去往下跌
甚至是上去往下跌
跌破这边的这个时候
哎呦嗯
翻黑咯
收了上引线咯
嗯 赞
棒棒棒
我的部位会在这个地方空下去
这边留了一个上引线
防守在这里
你可以懂这个想法吗
我希望他的力量是由上往下
这样子,这才是跟我要做空方的假突破
是有关的嘛
这样可以理解吗
所以你只能吃在引线的这里
所以当同学们在练边界乱打2-2的时候
我会强烈的要求这件事
哦,要求,这速度怎么那么快啊
好来继续
那如果有同学是吃在这种地方的下面这里
会被我念会被我打
这单我就不通过
他就要重打
所以有很多同学他待在边界乱打
二之二待了好几个月
一个月两个月三个月
因为他到处在练习
撞墙也不能
然后接到了吃也不行
我们就只有那么那么机车
就只能吃在那里
这样
只能吃在那个开高低收的
那个干净边缘的
旁边这里
而且你还要等到这一根的收
你后面才有东西
用我的吃法做波段
真的很好用
耶
看来
看来我赚不到了
好
来继续啰
如果是60K末端5K有图可以吗
很好
我很喜欢这种东西
就是看来拜拜了
拜拜了
我没有打算做哦
这个图很凶
而且各位
前面这个小10k
尖尖的长在这边
这里又有这样
其实这种图
对多头是很不利
我很不喜欢
那这是不是又是我们讲的概念
这边这边这边
同样的概念
对吧
好吧
希望他能够杀下来
到下面让我吃
好继续
我们现在讲到边界乱打
二之二对不对
这还不是交易的全部因为二之二的目的是在下沙的时候一个行情沙沙沙沙沙它会打两只脚懂?懂?下来第一个点
第二个点,我都有一个口诀
叫大家两点一线
而且是水平的
连绝对没有这种
没有这样子,牢狱牢狱,两点一线
没有,也不能这样子
你一定是平的
这边下来
弹起来
来到这个地方
最后这个点
拜托一定要干嘛
打破前一个点
要破哦
这个地方有没有破很重要哦
要破哦好不好
边界乱打二
咚咚
破了回来
隔壁是你的咚持下来
那这边如果是这样子哦
如果是这样子
一大堆上引线K棒下来
整理整理整理又是上引线
K棒都下来
又是上引线
K棒下来
这边来到这里
就算他破
这边这张单子都很难做了
因为他距离这个压力太近了
一大堆引线在你面前
这个
我现在没有办法好好的去
去跟大家说
我看他眼前有什么东西
哦来
如果你要在这里做多
这里
这就是我讲
距离压力只有10点
不是很好做
现在的波动超快
不要啦
這是給前面已經累積了1000利潤2000利潤的人
你拿個300500進來玩那ok
但是我沒有累積到
所以現在不關我的事
我想要等開盤
這樣好嗎
來還有喔
接下來前面的動態練習這個階段
我都需要你在未知行情
也就是在即時盤的情形下
你才有辦法練這個
那如果你是上班族白天很忙
你可以在晚上的时间利用那个Tradle Bay免费账号
不开户不付钱的免费账号
在晚上的时间用replay的方式
例如说我今天都没看原油
就把原油随便找个热门时段打开来
然后就给他用快速的拨
找到这个一个点两个点
两点一线破
破吃
我現在就在計畫如果這邊有破吃那個就會是兩點一線要出現的東西對吧好那你就要在即時盤的時候才能夠練到
所以這些練習動態練習
這些
不能在已經知道行情的下去練
沒有意義
你早就都知道看到解答的回來練
這不行
你必須要在未知的心情下
這個練習才會留在你的腦袋裡
好不好
我沒有打算吃哦
這邊這個上影線我很討厭
很討厭喔 好不好
那再來
前面動態練習完了
接著兩個靜態練習
你可以放鬆一下
讓自己心情緩一點
怎麼練?
標準圖的辨認
好
例如說
我們就把15K打開來
你就回頭開始找
這個是小那
你就開始找
你要找空方的也好
多頭也好
這邊有一個
这个
如果这个不是假突破
什么是假突破
对吧
我这边要趁机带一个观念给大家
来
我们的目的就是要等边界
该发生没发生
先定义好嘛
所以大格局边界尖尖的
就是小格局的什么
来同学们
因为有同学一直在说什么
假突破跟尖尖的不一样
哦,这个应该是新同学哦
他可能没有看熟我们的影片哦
假图破等于上面的尖尖的
破底翻等于下面的尖尖的
大格局尖尖的就是小格局的破底翻
大格局尖尖的朝上就是小格局的假图破
所以这个地方我如果开60k
它一定是一个60k长这样子
你可以懂我这个想法吧
所以你就涂鸦这样子
然后呢,找一个电脑的资料夹
存起来就画一个这样子
然后存起来你就这样截图
然后它有存档的功能
就把这张图存进电脑的资料夹
然后你就标一下
这是标准图1
好就这样子
然后呢存档
然后你每天就是开始回头找
然后标准图2标准图3
标准图4标准图5
一路回头找
这样
我跟大家讲找的方法很简单
你就画一个标准图然后呢你就把它用半透明半透明然後就開始對這裡好像有耶好像有有耶好就把它畫起來
存檔
好
你就開始回頭找
找
更久了
你要找互換也可以
找破底翻
假突破都可以
隨便你自己找
然後你要找原油
黃金
小納
小稻
小SP
都可以
反正就是找你習慣的
那如果你是有在做
股票的同學
你可以用60k或是日线
一樣
這個東西
你就回去找
找你要的
例如說我剛剛不是說NVIDIA嗎
我們就NVIDIA
NVIDIA的日线
日线這個地方好像有破底翻
好像這裡有
好
你就把它塗鴉起來
塗鴉起來
我這邊畫歪了不要理我
反正你就把它塗鴉起來
存檔
這樣
那以我們的做法就是
我要求你去存多少
數量要出來
你看一張標準圖
記憶一次,兩張記憶兩次
三張四張五張
然後你看久了你就會看到像我們剛剛不是畫了一個空方標準圖嗎
這裡
你會對他越來越有信心
畫了一個空方圖,哇就下去
對吧
下去了
來這時候
老魚剛剛是不是說
我剛剛是不是講
这边这个上影线很讨厌
有没有
那我们刚刚是不是说边界二
边界来了
但是他没有说进去
就有没有边界二
没有
你就等嘛
对不对
好来
你就可以在这个辨认标准图的过程中
建立对标准图的信心
标准图会不会错
会
他一定也会错
他不可能随时是对的
但是一旦他做对的时候
再搭配下一个阶段练习的
顺向亚当
找盘整
找涨破或跌破
你就把这个翻下去或翻上去
以眼前来讲
来,眼前五分K要不要翻亚当
要
这个亚当一翻
咚咚咚,哦,跑到荧幕外面去了
咚咚,我是不是可以先预计好
如果这个五分K
成功
它是真的,我是不是可以预计
在
哎呦如果这个是真的
我可以在这个地方哦这里原来也有低点哎哦
那我可能可以待会可以在这个地方等待是想在这边
在這邊幹嘛?在這個地方出現我要的
在這個地方下殺
滿足區
出現我要的什麼?
標準圖出現在這個
這個18360
18400之間
我不知道
如果他該翻沒有翻
他這邊又收進來,如果他收進來
就會是該翻
卻沒翻,就是剛剛的
該發生卻沒發生
對吧?這個標準圖是不是就會慢慢的
成形
這個位置的成形可能還要一個小時吧
一段時間上去還有一段時間回來
這可能要一個小時
而尖尖的隔壁
目前看起來好像沒有發生
對吧?那我剛剛拉不培這樣走人是不是很棒
這樣想法OK嗎?
好來繼續囉
所以這兩個動作
來,等一下拉過來
這兩個動作是拿來讓你練習做交易計劃
而且練膽量,練你對標準圖的熟悉度
你看一張圖看100次
你總是會比看一次還熟悉吧
對吧?而且我們不是每一個地方都標準圖
如果你在,例如說
如果你是在,在在在在在
其實行情有點要停住,微微的
來,如果你是在這個地方
老于老于,这里这里有互换图
你在亚当满族区辨认标准图
这会被我骂,像这个这个这里
老于这里有互换,老于这个是标准图
屁啦,不是哪个标准图都可以吃的
他发生的位置对不对,他发生在底下的满族区
怎么会对啦,这边又是压力区
又是满族区,来收敛一下
我們來收斂一下一個多頭的標準圖
它只會發生在區間的哪裡?下緣
發生在區間上緣的標準圖
這裡就算有破底翻
我都不想理它
就算這邊有互換
對!因為它太難判斷了
我要的是行情下來
慣性改變的第一波
這個互換我畫歪的不要管它
我要的是那個海浪有沒有
剛起來的第一波
我錯過第一波我就不要了所以我現在會很簡單的是畫出如果這個邊界是對的用大顆度看好了大顆度這個邊界有沒有到很漂亮
我可能會畫下面一點點
因為這邊有這個邊界這個邊界
所以我大概就知道好我就是在這個邊界裡等他
所以進到短顆度裡面我要不要急
不用急因為距離這一段還有什麼
我就可以在旁邊丟棒球
對吧
彈吉他
做別的事情
看我的Netflix
我做任何的閒事
陪老婆看影片
吃零食都可以
我就不用急
我就可以在那邊等待
那你說老魚來到這個地方
他一定會很精準嗎
不會
但是我心中就知道
這就是一個區域
我看他來到這個區域
他發生什麼事
而且如果是5分K
他來到這個地方
假设他真的来了
真的来到这边
要整理出我能够打了标准图
大概一个小时吧
所以价格来了
我要不要挤
不用
我就花
我可以有一个小时的时间
好整以暇的等市场
在这边震荡
打出低点
惯性改变
这才是我的
而这些练习
都在这个过程中
一路这样子练
这样好不好
有同学说今天
干货很多
亚当透明的快捷键
以苹果来讲是按着那个common
像蝴蝶一样的那个标示
以window来讲
是按着control
所以就是你就是这样子
结好图
你就结好一张图
就是这样
比如说结好这张亚当图
按这个按钮锁住
贴到萤幕上
然后呢按着control
或是common然后滑鼠的滚轮
滾轮
就可以滾
它的透明度
100自己调
这样
我喝个水
等一下
好
上面有同学问好问题
大格局尖尖的小格局
破底翻长得歪七扭八
那我就不做了
各位
如果你看破底翻看习惯
我這邊要講一下我們的標準圖的辨認
不能辨認這種斜斜的標準圖它很快就撞牆,這不给过也不可以是右脚小小的,然后这边有点往下斜的这样子
像小儿麻痹一样的这样子
不行,这也不给过,我们要的
标准图是
上平下平
右边可以稍微高一点,没关系
这代表往上有力,因为我是要做多的人
底下这个地方
我需要它是平的
它可以有一點點的下引線搓下來可以
但是它不能有一個引線搓這麼深來碰這個地方
這樣子是不行的
所以剛剛的五分K
來
這個五分K的這裡
這裡
這就是我們講的一個上頻下頻還不錯的概念
但是我不想做的原因是因為
這裡一大堆這個東西這樣掉下來
我覺得而且它的15K 60K很醜
所以我一看到就不想做
所以我当时的想法就是这样
来现在看
有没有继续往下掉
有没有
对不对
老鱼在说
你有没有在听
然后在短格局里面开始出现
出现什么
出现惯性的改变
有了开始出来了
这是在一分可以很短的角度
好吗
所以不可以是
不可以是下面的这个线
不可以是歪的
然后上面的这个
这个也不可以是往上的
不行
它需要工整
而且哦
还有一个想法
左边如果宽度是这样子
右边很急速的下来
左边这么宽
这个上礼拜好像讲过
右边的窄窄的这种
我不喜欢
我需要它的左右的宽度
有约略的样子
你看一下这个1分k
1分k
有没有看到
它有约略的样子
这没有到很美了
但是它有那个概念
概念有
这样了解吗
好不好
那你看哦如果
如果这个
15分K还有5分钟这个15分K
会收如果15分K收进这里面
约略就好了其实现在已经
很明确的概念
那是不是也连带会
让小10K出现
这个角
对吧各位可以理解了吗
所以我才会说大颗度
我刚刚是不是在行情最末端这边
我就说行情下不去的
有没有
大颗度的尖尖的一定是短格局的像这边一定会有一个破底翻可能会在这里如果待会如果有可能会在这
好吗
我不敢跟你说左右的长度
一定完全精准
左边三根右边就是三根
没有这回事不可能精准
但是我需要它约略
你的眼睛会告诉你
所以只要你一个好的标准图
像这我刚刚不是画了一个空方图吗
我们刚辨认的那个
你看多了
你自然就会知道
不对的图是长什么样
因为你看太多对的图
你知道我过去是念放射科
在医院的时候
我们就问那个医生
哇你怎么一眼就把那个S光片插上去
你如何一眼就辨认出肺结核的样子
他说因为我脑袋里面储存了几千张
没有生病的S光片的样子
那个人的肺部的S光片
没有生病的样子就是这样
几千张就是长这样子
没生病没生病
没生病没生病没生病
这个这里有多个白点
怪怪的
他知道他怪
然后就知道
这个怪怪的去检查
有没有
就是这样子
我问他说你怎么知道
这医生亲口跟我说的
因为他看太多没生病的样子
你自然就知道有生病长什么样子
对吧
还好他没告诉我
他得过
那个年代也没有什么戴口罩的意思
好不好
那打图阶段就是要综合刚刚前面的这些状况
把它接在一起
这样啊
然后
亚当的练习就是什么
找出两条线
突破翻
所以你先定义出边界
突破的翻它
定義出邊界跌破的
注意喔 不是引線收在收回來的喔
像這種K棒我需要他一大根
乖乖的收在外面
如果是下殺的K棒
他的收盤架要收在本來的整理區間的外面
他要能夠引起一大堆人停損的連鎖反應
這樣子才有意義
這樣好嗎
你不能是邊界
然後又縮回去
縮回去這個根本就不用翻
這還會變成我很喜歡的東西
好不好
然後所以綜合上面
剛剛前面講過的
這些順序
先學會畫兩條線
然後再學會在兩條線的邊緣
等待什麼
等待尖尖的吃
然後接下來就是變成是
這個地方其實有一個
小互換可以吃
不要啦各位不用太急
五分K的人
我跟你說你等這個都不吃
真的
你雖然不會吃到400這麼低
但是你會吃的單子會穩定很多
好不好
对五分K来讲
跳空要翻吗
要
但是以我们平常在做交易的练习
我不要大家去练翻跳空的
因为跳空不好翻
有可能一下跳空下来
一下跳空上去
我只要你去翻这种
像这个眼前就是一个很棒的练习
两条线跌破
翻翻把它翻出去
这样
把它翻出去这样子
把它翻出去这样
这就是我要做的事情
这里有没有两条线
有
那一个标准图就是什么
画出两条线了
跌破了以后
它又再走回来
如果行情只有走到这里
各位注意看
如果行情走到这里
这样
各位请问
这样子是不是一个均衡的破底翻标准图
是吗
这不是均衡的图
完全没有哦
左脚很大只右脚很小只
这一定跌倒的啊
对吧
这种不能做
好不好
那如果是这样子呢
然后这里
这个老鱼
左脚右脚在这里
好做吗
不好做
因为你一做下去
哇有尖尖的没错
你尖完了在这边有尖尖的没错
沒錯 煎完了就撞大牆壁
不要 不要 不要 不準
所以一個好的東西是什麼
是它還要從這邊整理一下
然後再下殺 殺殺殺殺殺殺殺殺殺
來到這裡 K-Bomb本來很大根
來到這邊 K-Bomb 慢慢變小根
長角 變小根 長角
長角喔 有一個角 稍微破了一下
讚喔 這個點
隔壁这个就会是
880这里
对不起
480这里
就会是我的吃点这样想法可以吗我今天可以把那張圖分享給大家實際上在我的我的FB上面的那個字頂文
好像第二則吧
他就是這個
就是這個表格
我早就放上去了
其實
畫標準圖
來
如果
基本上我們是只要引線到了就要畫
但是如果是這樣子
這個邊界很明確
來到這裡這裡
整理整理這裡
突然間只有一個引線
這樣一點點下去
可以可以
我可以
就是你就畫到這個
K棒的這附近OK
但如果它是這樣子喔
它的引線是很
這邊這個地方
帶著上引線下來
然後來到這個地方
如果它是這樣
下去又回來
引線來到這裡
下引線
這樣子
這個引線
哇
很尷尬了
因為上面又是壓力
底下又往下
這整個圖的力量就開始往這邊走
我沒有辦法給你
現在就給你一個精準的定義說
到底哪裡能怎麼樣這樣子
好不好
但是基本上
我們希望它的圖形上
你看久了
你會知道
這邊是穩定的圖
還有
例如說這一根
这根有没有长破
这个同学问到很长的引线要不要翻
来
它的收盘就好收在上面
你就要翻
但是我不会要你去翻这个
不会
练习不要翻这种
剧烈引线缩进来的
不要翻
因为这同时间也代表着
代表着来翻过来
K棒实体K棒对起来
它也代表着后面力量很强
会往这边走
对吧
不行
可以理解吗
你就去翻那种一根K棒
大大的满满的
把边界走出去
像这个就是他应该出去
却没出去
这种
有同学说黄金来我们看黄金
我们用任何一个商品
来
这根要不要翻亚当
这根要
对吧
他是不是长破了一个前面都长不上去的点
对
你就把它翻上去
他说照道理讲
應該要突破它走到這邊
所以如果上去有回來的這個互換
你要做多可能有道理
對吧
我看一下這個行情其實上面這邊很明显来来来来又来了尖尖的如果你直接在
没有人躲的
行情下去做空
很累对吧
你会先很容易在这个地方先被
停损这里所有的空单都没有人
躲没有人挡子弹
对不对
好吗
所以翻小10k
如果也是引線很長也跳過
好了小10k我们看一下
眼前黄金的小10k
来
这个要不要翻
一根k棒很明显跌破
一大堆不该跌破的点翻
底下
这根要不要翻
要
一根k棒涨破好多上不去的点
翻
这根要不要翻
要這根K棒收盤這樣
我們說在上面翻
它的引線基本上都還沒有很長
如果這根K棒的引線
是這樣子縮進這個邊界內
變成一個長上引線
然後K棒小小的這樣
這就不要翻它了
好不好
要不要翻翻
咚咚出去
你自己看翻出去
你就知道滿足區差不多
就這一段咚咚翻出來
你就知道航行來到這個地方
其實要注意可能是滿足區
你看果然就差不多
對吧
這樣OK嗎
底下這一段來這裡
黃金的小10K
這一根有沒有一個很明確的K棒突破
這裡有
我們不是在這時候才在做多
我們做多在前面早就下不去的
邊界賭翻亞當
賭撞破上面翻亞當
撞破了翻翻
你看出去了
有沒有
這樣可以嗎
哇塞
这个小娜
哇刚刚这里有一个
1分k等级的
边界乱打2就这里
这个
1分k等级的这样
哦
但是现在上去的有没有关系
跟我们讲的都一样很好很好
上去再回来的这个地方
哦我就可以规划了
待会如果我这样子这会是我的
如果这边再回来这边要小心哦
這邊不見得就很美了
好不好
再高一點再回來
這回是美麗的
唉呦9.51了耶
好嗎好啦其實今天基本上我所有的交易都讲完了那你会看到说我分批的吃啊什么的这些都是建立在
这些标准动作下的产物
所以初期我会允许同学
对不起
初期不允许同学有太多自主性
你要先把标准动作
在这个既定的框架内先练好
等你练到自由打单的时候
有些同学很爱用EK
OK他EK打得好给你去用
有些同学做空很厉害
做多不厉害OK你去做空
所以这时候就可以开始发展
每个人不同的打击知识
但是都是建立在一个大方向
都差不多的形象
然后你可以开始去发展
你自己的样子
有人喜欢做5K
有人喜欢做15
有人喜欢做日线的股票
OK
这时候的自主性就可以发生了
就沒有說你一定要怎麼做
沒有沒有都可以
這樣好不好
所以所有的這些包含我們常常出場的位置
很多同學喜歡在亞當滿族區出場
一出場就掉下來像這個剛剛
如果出場的都很棒啊
甚至剛剛前面不是有同學說
這個你看在
這個就是一個很美的邊界
這個
我剛好吃的點就在這
我的腦袋裡其實就是這樣
這個互換
又尖尖的
我的吃點
來
有沒有
先試3
我躲在這個的後面
有沒有看到我的出手
尖尖的這邊
試一下喔
有沒有看到
然後就是這樣子
我在試這件事情
而且你看我第一個試的
叫493
這個地方是490
我493試的位置在這個裡面
也对,我试在边界的内侧
我还是没有试在下面
有没有
哇,这个1K的互换
好了,没办法,算了
好了,今天就这样子
所有的东西都在这
OK,那你说建议用哪一个时区做功课
用你习惯了就好了
我没有办法给你一个精准
如果你習慣做當充你要做5分K的功課
或15K的功課,我覺得都很OK
這樣子
如果你是做股票,大概就是
就是小10K,還有那個什麼
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:10:00 起〕